he just finds the way and here actually  Magnus is obliged to trade Queens  Queenie through checking H1 and there's  no there's no follow-up actually the key  difference now is that the White Queen  protects her Knight on F4 right so that  trick uh we saw in the last variation  just doesn't work also I want to point  out like let's say queen E3 check King  H1 let's say Rook takes B2 just to try  and get a nice little mate in four here  Rook takes H7 we're probably gonna see  it Laura the king is going to go to the  corner and uh well since you're a piece  down you might as well for example going  for checkmate yeah yeah and now a lovely  Rook takes Pawn again just removing a  key Defender Knight G6 and it's over  seven is a mate it is over Magnus  Carlsen loses to another Indian teenager  it's a massive win for gukesh at only 16  years old he becomes the youngest player  ever to beat world champion Magnus  Carlsen after he became the world  champion